[Music]
Chuck Gary hey star talk sports edition
we gotta do another explainer all right
the time has come and it's something
none of us have any expertise in we're
going to talk about cardiac emergency
which has been all the news especially
of course since the uh incident in
recent weeks of Demar Hamlin in the NFL
just dropping down meeting CPR just to
get them off the field and take him to
the hospital with leaving everyone
mystified what happened what are they
doing to him will it happen to me all of
the above so we need a fast explainer on
this and we combed the world and we
found someone who's just right for this
we've got medical doctor Lippy Roy Lippy
welcome to StarTalk sports edition hi
everyone it's so good to be here good to
see you again Neil excellent yes we
actually just met at a separate
conference you know a few weeks ago and
I said yeah yeah I want her for Star
Talk so thanks for this fast turnaround
on your schedule and what I particularly
like about your background is not only
that you are a physician of internal
medicine but anybody could be that
you're also a masters in public health
and public health has been so much in
the news throughout covid throughout
anything else that we're all trying to
do in a society and so the combination
of your medical doctor's background and
your public health background I find to
be completely ideal for so many
questions that we have and I just want
to let people know that your frequent
commenter on uh on MSNBC NBC and for
Forbes and you've got a YouTube show let
me get the name of that right Health
humor and Harmony
yeah yeah so it sounds like a rap group
from uh it sounds like a prompted rap
group that's a lot more positive oh yeah
it's not Bone Thugs
in harmony that's right I wish I was
that cool I'm not as cool as you Chuck
no way all right so Libby in a few
minutes we have for this explainer could
you sort of unpack clinically the
difference between Cardiac Arrest a
heart attack and heart failure is there
a difference I know most of us use them
interchangeably but it seems to me that
they're not all the same when you're
coming from where you stand
yeah so first of all thank you so much
Neil for having me on your show I'm so
glad to be here you this is a topic
that's so important to me as an internal
medicine physician I actually have cared
for many many patients with all forms of
heart disease I was telling Chuck and
get your producer Gary earlier that
personally I'm affected by this my own
father had a heart attack 20 years ago
and is now struggling with consequences
or complications such as heart failure
heart failure so
um it this is a really important topic
and you're right Neil these terms are
used interchangeably but they mean
different things
um so uh and before I start because
humor matters to me and then Chuck is
going to care about this I want to start
with a silly joke why did the patient
refuse a much needed cardiac transplant
oh that's easy because uh he lived in
America and we don't have good health
care
that's the real reason but the joke
reason is that he had a change of heart
all right so I know Chuck you can
totally criticize that from a comedian
oh there's no no need
so so
It'll ask so it's
safety uh Buffalo Bills player Demar
Hamlin struggle experience a sudden
cardiac arrest on the field that simply
means that your heart abruptly stops
pumping and so that the lack of blood
flow to the brain and other vital organs
and without immediate medical attention
specifically CPR and defibrillation the
person will lose Consciousness become
disabled and could die so then what's
heart attack a heart attack is when the
blood vessels that supply the heart
which are called coronary arteries when
those blood vessels get blocked either
from like a cholesterol plaque or a clot
that uh clogged artery can no longer
Supply much needed blood to that part of
the heart and if it if it's for a short
time then that's ischemia which means
low oxygen to that part of the heart but
if it's prolonged period of no blood
flow to that part of the heart then
that's called infarction or Mi is
myocardial infarction which is the
technical term for a heart attack and a
heart attack by the way is a leading
cause of cardiac arrest and then Neil
asked about heart failure so heart
failure really means that your heart
just is not pumping sufficiently or it's
not filling with blood appropriately and
as a result vital parts of your vital
organs like your brain and other organs
aren't getting sufficient
um blood and so heart failure is the
leading cause of heart failure actually
is coronary artery disease okay so heart
failure is something that
um this the heart is not living up to
its specs is what's happening there
exactly the consequences to that so what
actually happened to Damelin
so great question so we know by the way
let me just also as a disclaimer say
I've never personally treated him so I
so I don't know I don't have access to
actual medical records but however there
have been enough there's been a lot of
information you never treated him before
the event I was like huh covering your
ass there huh
never before now after let me just
selfish I don't know if your your
listeners know this but he has just been
released from Buffalo General hospital
he is now discharged home I cannot begin
to tell you what an absolute Miracle
this is because statistically 9 out of
10 cardiac arrests that happen in the
field have an adverse and actually fatal
outcome so the fact that he's alive is
because of two reasons one he had
immediate chest compressions and
fibrillation or that defibrillator the
AED
um and the fact that he's a young and
otherwise completely healthy guy that's
what really what worked in his favor but
Neil he had download Damar Hamlin
experienced a sudden cardiac arrest on
the field we speculate it's because that
that tackle triggered what was called
commodio Cordis which is again a fancy
word to say basically
um uh an agitation of the heart so the
timing of that Collision happened at a
cycle of the electrical impulse so that
it caused A disruption and the heart
just stopped that's all that we know
beyond that there could be other
information but the hospital has a
really disclosed but that's what we know
so far in terms of his credit is so it's
kind of like uh if you're at a party and
somebody uh not bumps into the DJ table
and the record skips but kicks the plug
out of the wall and the Music Stops
yes it's exactly like that yeah
there's another term right here called
blunt force trauma which would describe
an NFL tackle
um so when you've got this event that
happens tragically what are the primary
care musters for the First Responders
who get there assess decide what
treatment is required how what what are
they thinking what is their primary must
Do's in this event because this is
what's really saved his life well well
if there's any kind of positive out of
this event look I'm sad that this
happened to Demar but I'm really glad
that he's doing well but what it really
did is bring really National if not
Global attention to CPR or really BLS
which is basic life support everybody
and their mother should be trained in
basic life support because you never
know when somebody's gonna collapse do
you think anyone expected this Elite 24
year old athlete to just collapse like
that so but this could happen in your
house on the sidewalk everybody needs to
know CPR the training is free you can go
to First Aid ah American Heart
Association and get that training so so
Gary that's one thing learning CPR is
life-saving you do not have to have the
letters MD behind your name to do that
and you could be 10 years old you can be
89 years old to learn cpra B have aeds
automated external defibrillators nearby
I don't know if every house should have
it but if you live with people that are
at higher risk for having heart disease
heart attack sudden collapse stroke get
an AED and know how to operate it
operating is actually really simple you
literally press the on button and then
it tells you what to do so those two
basic
um strategies uh Gary are going to be
key but really BLS will teach you check
for a pulse are they responsive are they
breathing those are the basic things
Gary so as a positive Neo
um the defibrillator my father had a
heart attack on a transatlantic flight
and the cabin crew pulled out a
defibrillator and brought him back so
yeah to talk to the doctors you know
that's the experience at my personal
level of understanding exactly why that
is so necessary so I mean I I look Neil
at um yes we've got a young athlete a
professional athlete who's whose life is
not more important than someone else's
life
but the focus of attention and media is
there imagine now what it must be like
to be the chief physician the first
responder the person responsible doctor
please because not everybody looks at it
from this point of view what goes
through the mind of someone who is
charged pun intended bad one with
bringing this man back to a safe and
healthy Place uh yeah so look at the end
of the day we're trained professionals
this is what we're trained to do it's to
save lives at the one extreme but really
improve the quality of life that said
I'm sure that there are many of trainers
that were with feet just a few feet away
so that's another major reason why he
would he had this positive outcome
um but yeah it's nerve-wracking I I've
been in icu's ccus
um emerging departments I've been uh in
homeless shelters working in clinics
wait what is this what is a CCU coronary
cardiac care unit and I assume Intensive
Care Unit so
CCO is specifically for
um cardiac patients that are critically
ill yeah my father brother have all been
in ccus I rotated through ccus I also
trained at Duke which is very a major
cardiac center in a place where where
people go to train in cardiology so uh
but it can be very nerve-wracking even
for healthcare professionals Gary uh as
a doctor even I get nervous but you know
your adrenaline and adrenaline and
epinephrine's pumping up so high that
you just you just act the impact that
this had emotionally and psychologically
and on the teammates culturally family
members culturally it's totally but this
is why I'm glad we're having this
conversation because just so your
viewers all understand heart disease is
still the number one killer of people in
the United States and globally number
one but the good news is we know how to
prevent it so so that's why I'm glad
we're having this conversation no one's
going to take the the steps that okay so
doctor we because we don't know the case
specifics for Demar Hamlin
um there is a condition and I'll
probably mangle it it's hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy which is a gene mutation
I believe that we have seen athletes all
of a sudden just drop down dead once
they're in an athletic event or they
just finish and Bank something goes
completely wrong am I right that 85
percent of the people who have this
condition go undiagnosed
yeah so I want to make sure we don't
we're not conflating issue so when an
athlete can you're right collapse but
there could be multiple reasons for that
hypertrophic hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
pretty much as the name explains
hypertrophic just means enlarged big
cardio heart and myopathy is really any
type of dysfunction or weakness of the
muscle so in HCM let's just call it that
um the the heart muscle gets really
enlarged and as you pointed out uh Gary
most of the co the cause for it is
genetic
um and the the heart the muscle
particularly that left ventricle which
is the one that pumps is a pretty
muscular uh part of the heart uh chamber
in in HCM the the walls the septum which
separates the left and right ventricle
that wall and the left ventricle the
walls get really thick
um again they're actually over 30 genes
that are involved in hundreds of
mutations within those I think 15 genes
that are involved but um hypertrophic a
cardiomyopathy can lead to a cardiac
arrest because it's associated with it
can be associated with fetal arrhythmias
like ventricular bfib or vtac
ventricular fibrillation how do we
diagnose it how do we know in advance so
that you don't put them out on the field
and die yeah it's a great question so
basically what you're asking so how do
you screen for HCM the thing is that HCM
is actually really rare
um you know one in 500 or maybe 600
000 uh to maybe about 1 million people
in America have HCM yeah that's the
important thing to remember is very very
few people which with HCM actually get
sudden Cardiac Arrest maybe one percent
okay so it's very very rare event most
people can live long and healthy lives
but screening
um I actually don't know if all
professional athletes get screened for
it but the the most common Oasis screen
for HCM are through an EKG which is an
electrocardiogram you put electrodes on
the chest or an echo cardiogram which is
uh or tte which is really an ultrasound
of the heart okay got it and and so I
have a question a statistical question
before we because we got to wrap very
soon
uh in foot in American football
people are tackled all the time
in their chest this is not a rare thing
and in fact everyone who saw that tackle
said that was a normal tackle so if
there's the risk of this pressure on the
chest happening at the exact wrong time
in the heartbeat cycle why doesn't this
happen way more often in this game
the short answer to that Neil is that we
don't know but I will tell them
great look great that's very honest
right right but but statistically this
is really a rare event to your point
Neil these these collisions happen all
the time it is the the core of the game
and yet unlike some of these other
conspiracy theorists who will say that
oh the this Cardiac Arrest these
athletes are dropping like flies and
they're they're associating it with the
covet vaccine which is totally false
there is no connection
um we don't really know but it's it's
truly a rare rare situation so the
commodio quartus uh you know that that
sudden agitation of the heart the sudden
Cardiac Arrest are extremely rare events
look I'm a big fan of hockey hockey
collisions happen all the time do they
all drop like flies and they have
Cardiac Arrest no they don't so it was
really a rare fluke event these athletes
are otherwise extremely healthy people
so so I now do these professional
organizations need to do more screening
I I don't really know but again it's
really really rare
um yeah so we've had in my my version of
football Neil we've had players collapse
on in the middle of the game but greatly
there's two famous ones Denmark's
Christian Harrison and an English
football player called from Bruce Moomba
and a cardio specialist walked out at
the stand
treated him there and then saved his
life that's without getting hit right
there's no there's no Collision this
just is a collapse right um so the the
the the the public attention the
consciousness of this now being an issue
like Lippy said it takes that to read
sadly over Consciousness sadly it does
but hopefully there'll be a positivity
comes from this tragic event right and
uh
hopefully the positivity is that people
will take uh better care to learn more
about how to how to prevent it for
themselves because heart disease is the
the number one killer and uh you know as
you get older you know things like
congestive heart failure uh um and and
and uh heart attack are are very very
common and when when you take care of
yourself through all the crap we say you
know your proper diet exercise all this
stuff that nobody wants to hear you know
you're extending your life you really
are it's it's that simple ending on up
notes here so very excellent Libby a
delight to have you here and uh the fact
that you are uh uh active in public
health makes you one of society's Heroes
and I I just tip my hat to your entire
career of what you've done for homeless
people and uh people in prison uh just
the general health conditions of people
who need it most and all that you think
and all that you do and all that you've
shared with the public just keep at it
and we're going to come back to you for
more for sure yeah I'm thrilled to hear
this can I just say quickly the three
biggest risk factors to decrease a
person's risk for heart disease it's
high blood pressure high cholesterol
smoking get those under control you will
decrease your risk of of getting heart
disease heart attack and maybe even the
Congress I'm so happy to be here with
you you guys are so great funny smart
I'm I'm so honored to be on your show
all right we got it
Libby's great to have you and of course
Chuck and Gary not so great to have us
no no not you guys it's a pleasure
this has been a star talk sports edition
explainer uh what's going on with our
hearts I'm Neil
keep looking up
[Music]